in this video we'll talk about T cell
and b-cell disorders this is a fan
requested video so in this video we
would learn four major diseases first
CVR combined immunodeficiency
ataxia telangestasia
hyper igem syndrome and viscot Aldrich
syndrome these are the four syndromes
that we would look at
so starting with severe combined
immunodeficiency as the name suggests
there is a severe compromisation of the
immune system so majorly the T cells are
significantly compromised and their
function is altered also there could be
problems in B cells and antibody
mediated responses
so there are two kinds first there could
be complete loss of T cells but the B
cells remain intact and in the second
type there could be problem in both
these cell types
so both the cell mediated and humoral
immunity is compromised in this case in
the earlier case only the cell mediated
immunity is compromised and the humeral
immunity is partially compromised
so obviously several aspects of T cell
and b-cell maturation is abrogated in
these conditions and that is due to
genetic defects
so let's see what are these genetic
defect
so among major cause of skid we can
understand there is a defective
interleukin to our gamma chain mostly
this is x-linked and recessive there
could be also defect in the gene that
produce adenosine diaminase
also there could be defect in the
recombinase associated Gene which are
required for vdj recombination so if you
broadly series all of these are three
important aspects of the development of
t or B cell so that is why T cell and B
cell activity is compromised let us
delve into details
so the il-2 uh gamma subunit il2
receptor gamma subunit is associated
with many important function and
maturation of different immune cells
so if the gene which encodes for the
common gamma chain for il2 receptor
is mutated then it leads to many
problems one of the problem is
maturation defect of the T cells
also this is associated with X
chromosome and it's an x-linked
situation
now this co-receptor is associated with
many other interleukin receptors such as
interleukin-7 which is very crucial for
B cell development so the mutation in
il2 can also compromise the B cell
development
interleukin-15 signaling can also be
abrogated that leads to a problem in NK
cell development that means one mutation
can lead to plethora of symptoms
now let's talk about the Ada deficiency
the Ada or adenosine deaminase is a key
enzyme which is required for two
important immunological process one is
somatic hypermutation and another is
class switching both these processes are
required for maturation of B cells and
basically it allows diversification of
the B cell mediated antibody production
without the class switching several
isotypes won't be produced and without
the somatic hyper mutation High Affinity
antibody cannot be generated
so if the enzyme that produce Aid is
basically compromised
then there could be B cell maturation
defects and again we can appreciate how
genetic defects can lead to immune
defects
then there could be defective vdjri
combination when there is a mutation in
the gene for rag1 and rag2 both these
Gene products are actually recombinase
these recombinase enzymes are required
for vdj recombination and as you all
know that vdj recombination is important
for antibody uh
production and also T cell receptors so
when these two genes are mutated there
could be functional compromise
compromisation of these aspects
next disease that we are going to talk
about is ataxia telengaxasia
this is a mouthful of term but anyway
this is very simple
so Ataxia calendarsium mutated or ATM is
a kinase that can recognize double
strand DNA brick and this is a very
useful enzyme because this particular
kinase is a sensor for double stranded
DNA break it can trigger a pause in the
cell cycle and recruit repair Machinery
in the double stranded DNA break and in
it it tries to repair that break and
resume the cell cycle
now once there is a mutation in the gene
that encodes for ATM
then there is a detrimental consequence
because there would be failure at
detecting DNA damage especially the
double stranded DNA ones then there
could be failure or halt in the cell
cycle progression so cell cycle would
anyway progress even if there is a
mutation or a double stranded DNA break
and that would lead to a lot of mutation
to be accumulated that can also create
problems in the development of the
immune cells
now there is a clinical Triad for the
itaxiathill injection and these clinical
Triad is known as Three A's first of all
there is cerebellar defects which is
ataxia
there is spider angiomas
and there is IGA deficiency in spider
angiomers there are specific spider like
skin patterns
so Under the Skin and this generally
appears either red or purplish
there is cerebellar defect which leads
to ataxia
that means a problem regarding balance
code motor coordination and speech and
obviously IGA defect can increase the
susceptibility for many bacterial
infection
now the clinical findings of ataxia
telexisia includes increased Alpha phyto
protein decreased IGA IGG and ige levels
lymphopenia cerebellar atrophy and it
increases the risk of lymphoma and
Leukemia
now let's talk about hyper IGM syndrome
as the name suggests there are too much
of IGM antibodies why is there a why is
there too much IGM antibody
so let's see
so this particular disease happens when
there is a problem in the cd40 ligate
cd40 ligand is the signal 2 for B Cell
Activation series 40 ligand is present
on the T helper cell now when CD ligand
cd40 ligand mediated signal is defective
the B Cell Activation is not strong
enough
and this is an x-linked right
when the activation is not strong enough
that lead to many problems but before
that let me quickly tell you that
clinical features involve recurrent
infections recurrent pyogenic infections
in the early life and also infection
with opportunistic pathogens like these
ones
now B Cell Activation defect can lead to
plethora of problems first of all when
there is a b Cell Activation defect
there could be class switching problems
as well so basically when there is a
weak B Cell Activation class switching
doesn't happen
that means when there is no class
switching by default IGM antibodies
would be produced and that's why there
is a hyper IGM syndrome that means too
much of IGM antibodies in the
circulation other type or other isotypes
are not present and the core reason
behind this is a weak activation of B
cell or partial activation of the B cell
that doesn't trigger any kind of class
switching reaction so this is how the
entire genetic defect is linked with the
cellular defects
the last one is viscot Aldrich syndrome
which is a consequence in the due to the
mutation in the WASP Gene this code for
wasp which is an actin regulator
anyway we Scott Aldrich syndrome is
characterized by abnormal immune system
function generally immunodeficiency one
can see reduced number of IGG and IGM
but an increased number of ige and IGA
so there is an overall imbalance in
terms of different
antibody isotypes
there is also eczema that means
inflammatory skin disorder which is
characterized by radish patches and
irritation in the skin
there could be also reduced ability for
blood clotting
and indeed clinical presentation shows
that there are fewer and smaller
platelets
people can remember the clinical
features with the help of the
acronym known as water
so water stands for
viscot eldrich syndrome and the key
features are thrombocytopenia eczema and
recurrent infection
it also increases the risk of autoimmune
disease and malignancy
so I hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
you can support our Channel using super
thanks see you in next video